[Music]
Marjorie is with us in Austin Texas hey
Marjorie how are you hi babies how are
you better than I deserve what's up I am
in quite a bit of debt and I do have an
IRA with some money in it that I have
pulled out once before and been
penalized for it but I just wanted your
thoughts on should I go ahead and pay
off my debt with what I have in
retirement or leave it there nope leave
it there okay the only time I pull money
out of retirement to pay debt is to
avoid bankruptcy or foreclosure and you
didn't mention either so I'm guessing
you're not there no I'm not you know how
much how much dad have you got 27,000
okay and so what happens as you've
already discovered because you did it
once when you pull money out of an IRA
early you get charged a 10% penalty plus
your tax rate and so if you're in a 20
percent tax bracket that means you get
hit 30 percent so that's like saying
Dave I want to borrow money at 30
percent interest to pay off some of my
debt well that would be stupid
yeah and you wouldn't want to do it I
mean that's you said what I'm saying you
wouldn't but you weren't thinking about
it that way so I'm not saying you're
stupid but if once you put on the table
and you understand this is like borrow
money at 30 percent interest no thank
you I don't want to do that it sounds
like it sounds like it's easy but it's
not it's it's real you know the
long-term implications are ridiculous so
what kind of debt is your twenty seven
thousand credit card if you cut them up
yet I have one car payment too much do
in your car I 11 on my car what do you
make a year 42 good for you okay how old
are you 32 you're single I am okay but
I'm having trouble making it through
month to month with rent and that and
paying off the credit cards because I
try to put more towards them than the
minimum yeah don't don't until you have
a budget you need a written budget that
first takes care of food
then lights and water then shelter then
your car payment and car gas food
shelter clothing transportation these
are the basics of life once you've got
those done then you pay your credit card
payments and that's once that's done
then if you've got more money you pay it
on the smallest credit card
are you putting money into your 401k or
into retirement I'm stop okay well you
get out of debt temporarily are you
getting a big tax refund each year yes I
put extra money aside why and so I have
that cushion why it's a zero percent
interest you're loaning money to the
government and they give it back to you
and April with no interest meanwhile you
can't make your bills so how big was
your tax refund last year I actually got
penalized for the pulling money out so
much money how much money would your tax
refund be this year do you think
probably about eight hundred okay
so you've got you don't have to weigh
too much but you've got almost $100 a
month too much coming out yeah okay so
let's get that hundred dollars let's
stop the 401 K let's get on a written
budget a detailed budget jump on every
dollar it's free get that on good good
get to get your budget done tonight it
takes ten minutes give every dollar a
name take care of you first and then
play the game okay the game is the game
is get out of debt and all that crap but
you got to eat keep your lights on you
know you got to not be homeless right
right and then once you've done that
then okay it's just a game after that
this is monopoly and we got to catch up
and we're behind we need to pass go
collect $200 and get after it so that's
the other thing what we're gonna do for
your new extra job well thousand dollars
a month would change a lot of stuff
wouldn't it it sure would and I'm not
trying to do that problem once you work
extra the rest of your life but I want
you to work like a crazy person get this
stress off of you because you sound like
me like you're getting beat up oh I am I
am you know living paycheck to paycheck
and even if having to borrow money from
family members well let's pretend for a
second okay we've adjusted your
take-home pay with the 401k we've
adjusted it with changing your
withholdings so that you're not getting
a refund any more and you're on a new
budget which is going to make your money
work harder you're gonna feel like you
got a raise let's pretend that's worth a
thousand dollars a month okay let's
pretend you made at a part-time job
another thousand dollars a month that'd
be $2,000 $2,000 a month for 12 months
this time next year would be $24,000 you
only owe 27 exactly I almost got you out
of that in a year yeah you can do this
second you can do this and I don't want
you to work extra the rest of your life
but I want you get your mess cleaned up
so you get your life back okay okay that
makes a lot of sense Dave thank you very
much hey hold on I'm gonna give you a
Christmas present it's called the Total
Money Makeover it's the book that'll
show you how to do every bit of this and
you call me back if you're fighting on
this and getting scared and don't know
what to do that's what we're here for
I think you can do this you got the
chops just nobody ever showed you how
and I'm the guy that's what I do